picture a thousand women and suppose
that 1% of them have breast cancer and
let's say they all undergo a certain
breast cancer screening and that nine of
those with cancer correctly get positive
results and there's one false negative
and then suppose that among the
remainder without cancer 89 get false
positives and 901 correctly get negative
results so if all you know about a woman
is that she does the screening and she
gets a positive result the probability
that she's in the cancer group given the
test result is 9 / 99 + 89 which is
approximately 1 and 11 so the Paradox
here is that in one sense the test is
over 90% accurate it gives correct
results to over 90% of the patients who
take it and yet if you learn that
someone gets a positive result without
any added information there's actually
only a 1 in 11 chance that that
particular result is
accurate